i was on my way last night um
uh getting ready to lose my shirt and my
weekly poker um
that's the group uh so i did what i
always do on my way to pokers i popped
two shirts i popped on the uh the
thursday night football game and ion
eagle and this man with a highly
entertaining call i called up just at
the time as i heard him put the ziggy on
uh justin tucker
and ian called him out for tucker on
tucker violence that's what he said
and ross tucker here on the rich island
show it's been a while ross how are you
sir
rich i'm fantastic thank you for
listening last night it was great listen
you guys are great together rich you
should see
some of the tweets i got from people
that were listed in the game we've
gotten to the point now
where people really do believe the
announcers have that kind of power i
mean one guy tweeted me and said maybe
you should
stfu now oh
i replied back to him i said are you a
ravens fan or did you just bet on the
game
or it could have had justin tucker in
fantasy and that's a minus one you know
i mean i don't know if there's any
rational thought behind it but it was
just funny the way that ayan is so funny
and you the two of you together are
terrific man i enjoyed the listen quite
a bit i enjoyed it i i just only wish i
had been listening out or i was already
out of the car when the robert hunt
moment in the sun occurred
i'll just give
you sir
the floor on what this means for big men
everywhere to see him just live his best
life throw caution to the wind and hope
that nobody noticed a six foot six 200
327 pound man was ineligible
you know what do you think well rich i
mean it's one of my favorite plays ever
and i do i call a lot of games yes you
do and i'm so glad i was there for it
and there's just so many aspects of it
that are hilarious i mean
miles gaskins going out for the screen
and hunt turns around and looks for the
ball
like like it's for him
and he's the right guard i mean i think
i tweeted it was my favorite
touchdown pass to a right guard i've
ever seen i mean you know sometimes
there's tackle eligible there's never a
guard like that but what's crazy
is just how athletic he looks
he dove for the end zone and reached it
over the goal like he looks like you
know they always say act like you've
been there before he looked like he's
done it for i literally said blind
on the broadcast that he must have
played running back or tight end in high
school we tried to look it up during the
break and we saw he averaged 19 points
and 11 rebounds in basketball but we
didn't see anything about other sport
you know other positions and then i saw
his quotes after the game where he said
he played a little wide receiver inside
he had to i mean he looked he looked
legit with the ball of his hand i just
love that he made a move but the thing i
love too is that you know uh even i got
caught up in it too i thought he
could've been you know eligible but then
i'm like wait a minute he's an interior
lineman there's no way on planet earth
he could have been
eligible at all and but i guess
everybody except for him
gaskins and i guess
uh tua
had to know this was off but nobody else
could
so the everyone else was blocking like
it's a play and everyone else was
tackling like this is a play i
i i don't know why i just loved every
last second of it
that was amazing rich there was a split
second
where i thought i had missed something
right and that maybe he had lined up a
tight end you know because i
you know i didn't see the flag the fight
didn't come out right away for illegal
touching and i thought did he line up at
tight end like did they just run a
screen to robert on i mean it was you
have to understand rich right like
every person every guy that played
o-line
in junior high
high school pop warner nfl
we all lived vicariously through robert
hunt last night i mean look
i was glad to play in the nfl i love
playing line
but we all just once want to know what
it's like to have the ball now i played
full back in seventh grade scored a
touchdown i don't think about that every
day but that i mean honestly most of us
have never touched the ball so to see
one of us you know one of us that when
they were in third grade were was called
husky you know
now when they're or they're called a big
guy right we know what that means we
know what you're saying to see one of us
get in the end zone even if it didn't
count it meant a lot to our people rich
[Laughter]
ross tucker i think i think it mean it
meant so much to a lot of people not to
get too deep but what the hell to
anybody you know who works
so hard at what they do
and and it's a team effort at whatever
job that they do or whatever class that
they're taking or whatever they're doing
you know for the collective of whatever
the collective may be for them to just
say you know what screw it i'm just
going to like snap it like this to kind
of snap
and and take the lead when nobody when
it's not appropriate to or it's not
expected to just screw it and then just
go for the gusto and then act like
you've been there before and hope and
hope nobody notices it really was just
one of the greatest moments i've ever
seen on a football field and i'm not
exaggerating it really was incredible i
loved it every second yeah you know it
it's funny too because i don't think
people realize
just how athletic you have to be
to even be an nfl offensive lineman
right like
he has you know you he has 19 points in
basketball i'll never forget when i got
moved rich from defensive line to
offensive line in college
my
coaches at prince and they said do you
think you're a better basketball player
than the michigan offensive line because
your alma mater yes had just won the
national championship in 97 right and
you know i was a pretty good high school
basketball player so i thought no
they're not meanwhile then i get to
washington
as a rookie and like john jansen and
those guys john jansen got his first
scholarship offer was from michigan when
he was playing in the state championship
in basketball in 10th grade like you
can't be a slug
and be on an nfl field period like all
these guys
played tight end or played basketball or
maybe even you know played d-line
there's not a lot of them that were just
you know
big boned uh linemen their whole life
ross tucker of ross tucker football
podcast fame as well as uh westwood one
he called the game last night uh with
iron eagle and calls games uh all over
the map right here on the rich eisen
show let's just flip the script a little
bit here uh we hear about let's bury the
film et cetera et cetera when something
doesn't go well for a team that's
otherwise terrific with cowboys for
instance is one uh did the ravens have
the bury the film game last night what
do you think
on that one well i don't think they can
afford to do that because the dolphins
had a really good plan for them
that the ravens didn't solve all night
and i think that's probably the one
thing that people don't understand
enough about the nfl it's one of the
reasons why belichick and the patriots
have been so good
you know rich you have a totally
different plan or you come up with some
plan
every week that you think
accentuates your strengths and attacks
their weaknesses and it can look
that's why upsets happen
because the team has a really good plan
you don't have a good plan and that's
enough for them to be able to beat you
even though you're better than them now
certainly they just played the vikings
in overtime on sunday they played a lot
of snaps i mean they kind of looked like
a lethargic team and who knows if the
game would have been different i don't
know what sammy watkins was doing on
that first drive if the ravens got more
of a lead if i hadn't jinxed my brother
from another mother justin tucker you
know who knows what happened
but the point is rich they did the same
thing the whole night they came with a
zero blitz which means it's man-to-man
across the board they like their corners
byron jones and xavier howard and they
said we don't think lamar can beat us
against the blitz and they couldn't you
know that their corners matched up well
on the ravens receivers lamar was a
little off
and the ravens didn't have a very good
answer so they can't afford to bury the
tape because that's what the next team's
gonna do and the next team after that
until they prove that they can visit
that's why the way the nfl works you
know if you have an issue if you're bad
against the bull rush the next game you
play that guy is going to pull the crap
out of you until you prove you can stop
it
ross tucker here on the rich eisen show
it's our our new normal like right now
uh one game into week 10 so many teams
coming off of a bye
some teams have played their half of
their season a little bit more than half
of their season there's really no such
thing as half a season anymore it's kind
of right around now so
at this point the best team you've seen
with your own two eyes and all the
football that you've called so far this
year is which team
ross tucker
uh
i still think it's the bucks i mean i i
think you can make an argument for the
rams
i am unbelievably impressed
with what rayball has done with the
titans i mean i just
he is an awesome former teammate of mine
i i had no idea he'd be this this good
of a coach but i still think it's tampa
bay i mean they're a little bit banged
up right now
but i mean i always look at it like this
rich if there was a series of five games
played like in my backyard or played in
wichita kansas or something like that
who would i i would take the box now i
would still take tampa which is why i
half jokingly said
when the rams signed odell
i saw you know everybody says oh they're
all in and von miller and odell i said
well now all they need to do is get
brady and i guarantee they win it
all they need to do because here's the
thing rich i was thinking about this
and i know brockman's into this kind of
stuff
when's the last team to win it
with a quarterback who's never won a
playoff game
you know usually there's like you gotta
walk before you can run in the
postseason now usually you're doing it
with the same franchise and obviously
kurt warner your guy did it but i i was
trying to think who's the last team
where the quarterback won the super bowl
even though he had never won a single
playoff game before well i guess let's
let's let's game this out a little bit
here uh and it'll be easy since you know
brady we know brady's one of them right
from 2001 so we can we can then work our
way the other direction
um hmm
how about homes have won a playoff game
i i mean how about foals you know how
about that one
oh that that's right that's what that's
going to say that's a great call but
that's not i mean he came in
he yeah i know that like who's a starter
an entire year my first thought was
flying
but did flacco win a playoff game before
the year that they went into the summer
people won a bunch of playoff games
before they were flacco and harbaugh won
a playoff game like three or four
straight years before they won yeah
that's that that had to have been the
case right russell wilson hmm
i don't know well russ had won a playoff
game the year before they won it or yeah
right that's true i mean so here comes
so you think like again i don't know
hold on a second lions fans would say i
don't know why tj is getting up right
now because i'm about to slag on his
cowboys but you know lions lions fans
would definitely say that they won a
playoff game in in dallas but uh there
was a terrible flag so stafford kind of
won a playoff game oh ben
roethlisberger's rookie season that's
another one right there
well no no no that was not his work that
was not his working season he didn't win
the super bowl he didn't win the super
bowl that year
he won playoff games before winning it
yeah
that's that's an interesting thing i i
don't know man it might not be an issue
and he's got experience but i don't know
he's never been in nfc championship he's
never been in a divisional round game it
just seemed like that would be pretty
impre now folz did it so you had a great
answer but it would be pretty impressive
to win a divisional round game against a
good team you know the cardinals or the
bucks then you win the nfc champ i mean
that's that's a lot to ask of a guy you
know in his first kind of
playoff run so to speak well i mean
arizona clearly is going to be in that
conundrum when they make the playoffs
this year right and then kyler's gonna
get his first run
uh in the second season you know when
that happens and i know their their lone
loss came against a green bay team uh
that did not have devonte adams on a
short week and went in and hit him in
the mouth but
what do you think last one for i guess
about arizona's long-term prospects this
year then
yeah well obviously they're really
talented but just as as you and i are
talking through it
when we get to the
playoffs and arizona plays the packers
or arizona plays the bucks
i'm not picking arizona to win that game
i mean they might
but it's kind of like and i i shouldn't
be this way but it's kind of like i'll
believe
that the arizona cardinals and kyler
murray can beat aaron rodgers and the
packers or tom brady in the bucks when i
see it and i feel that way a little bit
about stafford and the rams and the one
thing i heard anybody mention is
i'm kind of wondering
rich if aaron rodgers is mad right now
with the packers you know that did he
want them to go in on odell we haven't
heard that but we know that he wants
them to be more aggressive kind of
sounds like if they were more aggressive
maybe they could have got him i haven't
heard anybody talk about what aaron's
thinking right now because maybe maybe
they lose to the rams in the nfc
championship game and odell has three
touchdowns and rogers flips out again
this all season well odell's first game
as a ram is going to be at green bay
because he's not going to play this week
then it's a bye week then they're at
green bay but to be honest with you i
think that that's just geography
i heard when it all came down to it he
was he either was going to go home to
new orleans or come to nice warm big
city los angeles
you know and like the big city uh and
von miller's friendship kind of trumps
everything and going and you know what
like that might have been it you know
that might have something it might be
much ado about nothing with rogers
anyway you know when it comes down to it
with with odell is what i'm saying
yeah and you know what i i'll give odell
a lot of credit in the sense that
it really wasn't about money and it
really wasn't about getting the ball i
mean i i do think
everybody likes los angeles all you guys
like living out there number one and i
also think
he wants to try to chase a ring so a lot
of guys say it's not about the money or
it's not about the touches he kind of
proved it
ross what are you calling this week i
know you got to go to a production
meeting what's next for you this weekend
uh so three games in four days i did an
action wednesday i did uh the game last
night and then [ __ ] now at army tomorrow
i do all the army games with cbs sports
network i love it that's so cool enjoy
that let's chat again soon maybe right
before army navy how does that sound
let's connect oh that'd be awesome yep
i'll be doing that game thank you i bet
you well thanks again that's ross tucker
right here on the rich eisen show for
big men everywhere hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here